ero ragazzo oggi video di cibo capitale
tanto contento di fare questo video oggi
chissà perché sta per questo marcio
allora specie se avete chiesto di fare
il in cui assaggiamo cose in cui
mangiamo come questo e un video in cui
assaggeremo di snack di tiger nello
specifico quelli di halloween ce ne sono
alcuni super particolari ha salvato ok
allora li abbiamo presi tutti tranne un
paio che erano tipo marshmallow perché
mano della fina di maiale quindi
anche quelli non dobbiamo avere rubarvi
sapete anche voi avete mangiato qualcuno
di queste cose e da cosa mi investirete
analogo
scriveteci nei commenti e forse niente
girate ci possiamo mettere non erano in
più da zucca e stiamo chiaramente tutte
le brame per un po quello di poi mi devo
allontanati tutti non dovevo assaggiare
quindi siamo a posto a quella suonata
iniziare non mangiare tutti ce la farà
dopo the iniziamo allora ma questi sono
gli ingiusti si vede meglio sono degli
gnocchi bulbi proprio stare a striano e
dai nostri occhi stando già citato per
il cioccolato è mai è fatta di
qualcos'altro descritto mura milk
djokovic
no veramente posti prepara il cibo non
so perché quelle richiedete ma è sempre
così vitale con una zona sempre chi ruba
il cibo anche piangere lo trova ancora
negli occhi
apriamo prendiamo un po chi è dentro la
scuola come scappaticci diretto tra
scattando tutti a stare assaggiando
dentro è ripieno cioè ripieno crema al
latte ordine a questo punto da di
franchi forse essere holy see rigori
sono fiabe normale che chi già ha sì lo
stesso adesso quindi dvd la condivido
nate appena detto ancora ce la faccio da
un altro non so se sentite
[Musica]
una persona forte allora penso che siano
reali sul piatto ma che hanno messo
dentro le caramelle frizzanti di tiger
quelle che fredda ho beccato bene a
quell'aspetto sorpresa dopo l'estate di
900 perfetto effettivamente adesso
abbiamo senza risposta ceduto essere
assaggiare i soldini
questi soldi sono dei soldini di
cioccolato con l'osso vicario in passato
di diversi uno sì sono io allora rischio
sfidati da dietro è morto davvero in
mente la stampa fatto il fantasmino e
poi ci abbiate dall'inter diamantino nel
canto
finalmente sbarcato a calcare i cani non
troppo bene
una grande e pura quindi immagine
diversa fantasmini integreranno allora
nella polizia dentro non c'è disegnato a
niente purtroppo viviamo in cui ghiaccio
proprio è mamma mia
non sentitevi atto niente nella macchina
[Musica]
normale su quanto nuovo al latte molto
molto nucara ball non è niente niente di
eccezionale si è stato nominato schaller
ha detto quasi perché quando stato
stoccato in via nessuno ma la signora il
casco appena ad ora ad essere invece
abbiamo da assaggiare
l'intera come dichiara manchin iii testa
di zucca si chiama di zucca testa di
zucca e come benedetta vediamo che ha
tracciato la line up qualche sorpresa
dentro sapranno di zucchero ripieno di
zucchero non c'è niente di studente
sempre una cosa è vuoto per niente
dentro
[Musica]
che tristezza
io jones che non sono con la commissione
ha detto che mandava in sono goloso
[Musica]
era lasciato il cioccolato quando te non
mi so nulla sapendo io non ho mangiato
ma ad oggi niente per te lo faccio più
niente ho solo io adesso allora quale
aspettiamo ha detto abbiamo finito lo so
cosa si direi di provare lo zucchero
filato
rimanendo in tema zucca orange clermont
e zucca perché nel fatto che non sono
italiani perché perché non ho pitarresi
mandato da zucchero scrivete nei
commenti risotto alla zucca barucca per
noi gestiamo del sud non è molto un uomo
ne sa nulla mangiamo contro lo zupo noi
abbiamo questo zucchero filato
all'arancia e il prof carroccio che ha
nella roccia però ha l'immagine di un
reietto che gli è comunque tema
halloween forse non tanto perché ti
complicato
non so con sapore particolare ti piace
tra l'altro se non avete visto il nostro
proviamo i dolcetti di tiger in esse mer
però mica troppo zucchero non si
proviene dall'area di questa sarà la
seconda volta tipi affitto però molto
strano molto particolare come contro nei
fatti se in questa cosa mi lascia sempre
molto perplesso da questo limbo tutto
pensiamo troppo grande dice una cosa del
genere però è troppo zucchero e zucchero
il ragazzo silvio del cristo sarà
contento è troppo buono primi camion e
un modo per chi arancio ma di mandarino
tipo ovvero travel all'arancia e
buonissimo questo vogliono la smetti
guardia fare meglio di cibo con vitale
perché dopo non nasconde fino a quando
melo che verranno di famiglia che è
partito gesù scherzetto potuto dare
tutta da questi qua sono pericolosissimi
perché io li mangia di tutti tutte che
guarda che questi sono i sapori tifosi
sono come quelle di rifondere schifo c'è
scritto una cosa ma che sono un altro
aspetto
e anche questo e poi chiudere per fare
danni
ora il prossimo dolcetto zucchero
affidato questo è verde ed è una mela
dovere più questo è il disegnino della
mela con i denti da vampiro super carino
questi potesse conservarli per fare il
nostro come contenitore il club sta
scherzando quando li deve avere altre
come che il figlio questo colore attuali
verde
io non direi sono gli slide
ma proprio perché ogni delle
microimprese mappa degli sly stati me
l'ha detta molto buona e rinfrescante ne
sa un po di dentifricio anche perrotta
[Applauso]
lamela carta promesse sito si metta
forse fa spendiamo metta al fallimento
ad assomigliare la mia dalla mera tutta
la vita le ha fatto un eccesso di
zuccheri dell'impatto guarda ora questi
li abbiamo aspettati qualche piaciuto in
più forse quello l'arancia amara cio non
berlusconi anche a me questo
sono stato sono in piedi mandarino
freschi questo è un po più bene allora
tra capitale fatica e chiaramente lo
dico spesso la vita non le comprare
questo e non lo voglio vedere perché se
tutte abusive non troppo jennifer quel
gene pino infatti a novara però vale per
qualsiasi cosa questa cosa mi hai detto
allora in pratica assistito halloween
beans e possono essere dei posti buoni e
possono essere dei gusti schifosi ad
esempio quello viola questa opera o
cipolla o si viaggia un peperoncino o
maniglia o giorgio center o mirtillo o
peperoni coca cola o no l'immagine di
quello marrone ha troppo in percorrenza
siamo fortunati andiamo quale possa
andare certo cinici sta ma non piangere
non dimenticato trasferito
tornerò presto blackberry dai pali segni
mettiamo qui per vedere allora blu barry
pepper il vero test così tenero come sta
bene secondo me un buon sistema per
farmi smettere di maggiore è vero
capiterà tifoso posso dirlo allora io
voglio rischiare e prendo quello marrone
il premio bianco vaniglia sensor vediamo
cos'è vaniglia zenzero grigio meno male
allora io mi butto su questo marrone che
potrebbe essere o coca cola o un pò
marzo non oso immaginare cipolla no
gestione che schifo
no questo di cipolla e riprovare questo
uovo marcio
no ancora il sapore in bocca ma piace
sentirmi lottando della cipolla oddio
santo terribili con olio tre amici
questo gioco pronto allora è proprio
quello rosso aveva un prezzo di un uovo
punita dai prova aperta
no ma questo cosa buona è stato quello
di sibolga e qual è questo qui cosa dove
dobbiamo abbiamo
[Musica]
direte di non buttare ancora comunicato
tipo attivo
[Musica]
secondo me fa più schifo quello di
cipolla non crediamo perché era un gusto
che dici non te lo aspetti di mangiarlo
la cipolla cruda nella una caramella
prima mette fortunata ma ce ne autorizza
di titoli mitico all'acqua spero di
simboli del nero assaggi del capo di
nuovo per una stranissima vero valentino
no vabbè ho detto la peggiore peggiore
del nuovo marzo di nuovo bergamo questi
brutti ma non so se rilievi se volete
fare gli scherzi se volete fare gli
scherzi dolcetto scherzetto da quella la
cipolla per l'uomo
l'uomo marzo a quasi tipo però cipolla
mi sento come gioca ci saranno le
diranno a me piace alla cipolla attacca
in rete vi sapore cipolla cruda
ma va bene così ho bisogno di contare
qualcosa di diverso non pensavo che un
video la stagione che sarebbe stato così
divertente loster letto volete vederne
altri
consigliatissimo per cosa allora qua
abbiamo dei noli q2 tema halloween con
diverse figure che vediamo giustizia
non lo so vediamo
[Musica]
non diverse allora abbiamo il ragnetto è
la ragnatela quale vuoi tu il nostro
magnetto vediamo se questo è non mi
piace abbiamo della micia gusto amici è
il linguaggio di carattere voler si sono
di menta e anzi tipo solo anni un po di
meta un po anziché di pecora sono carini
per un party halloween
oppure per darvi i bambini per dolcetto
scherzetto
ok allora parlerà anche di pesca di più
tutto il pizzo alla vaniglia questo
quale tutte la vaniglia il mese di cosa
mi piace dall 80 ma anche sul capitolo
zenzero
comunque sono la massa allo zero secondo
me anche la pena dipende mappa è
piaciuta incollandolo questi a te a me
non è mai piaciuto più di tutti questo
al mandarino
il pezzo è di tutti la caramella alla
cipolla 1 marzo o mio dio
[Musica]
questa caramella qui alla cipolla
appello inviato allora ragazzi fatica
per se volete vedere altri video assaggi
vitale ne sarà molto contento adesso per
light 6 descriverlo se questo video
raggiunti 10 mian iphone della mappa
neonato ma così potrò mangiare al foro
danteschi senza iscriversi che in troppi
zuccheri bastano più i medici che altri
che altre cose pratiche assaggiavano
prossimi video e ora vi lasciamo fa
quattro cartellini e poi cliccare per
vedere inoltre altri video nei nostri
salendo assieme ai nostri video
divertenti di zaia mal cliccate su
quello che preferite e buona visione
ciao ciao